people i'm i'm i've talked quite a bit
about the bill maher stuff basically
he's saying
you know dr seuss had this book removed
because of this depiction of a chinese
man with eating with chopsticks and he
says you know who doesn't care about
this
china all 1.4 billion could give a
crouching tiger flying f
about dr seuss's book they're building
infrastructure
they're building coal power plants
they're growing rapidly
so i always i always have this question
for a lot of the more uh um
liberty or i don't the right word is but
uh
capitalistic individuals and less
government how do you provide for the
common defense and i'm not i'm not
saying you don't i'm asking you quite
literally like
i mean i don't i think you're right i
don't the the common man doesn't need
defense the common man needs liberty and
bill maher he was a leftist then he was
a leftist when everyone disagreed with
him and he's a leftist when some people
now agree with him he does not believe
in capitalism he's always mocked the
idea of capitalism working
back when people on the right pretended
to be for capitalism bill maher was
public enemy number one because he said
things that you know a child thinks
about capitalism and here he is saying
the same thing he's always said
that capitalism screws the little guy
and
you know the difference is now
republicans and people on the right are
crazy about it
people hate me everyone doesn't want to
hear about it but you know the truth is
the truth
well so look china's growing rapidly
yeah they've got oil exploration in
africa and south america yeah they
they're are you familiar with the
concept of thucydides trap
no i was like beating a dead horse for
me to say because i say it all the time
on the show but
it's a general idea that when a rising
power is about to displace an economic
superpower
war breaks out so what in your view
would this world
or this country be like if we did not
have the common defense
would it just be like individuals who
are armed guarding their private
property and saying
no so i do believe in police and uh
military i'm not saying
we should abolish though i'm not an
anarchist that's that's the thing
anarchists
they're like uh a dr seuss um
bastardization of iran's philosophy
objectivism which i am i'm an
objectivist
anarchist uh they don't really have an
answer right now that i
there's one group of people i haven't
pissed off yet now i've got them all on
my back
all right now that everybody's angry now
that everybody hates me in the in the
event that uh
you know war breaks out what do we do
like it
what do you mean war breaks out war
breaks out they fire at us they're dead
they'll know that when i'm in charge
believe me it'll be very clear
but do do you think that there's like a
very strong free market
and then taxation would fund military
for common defense
well much more the amount of prosperity
we would see in a free market would be
just so
um just so high the average person would
have
change in his couch there's a dated
reference for you changing the sketch
something zoomers have never seen
in their life change that they find in
the couch yeah open days huh i mean
and prosperous okay look how
we have a volunteer military right now
right like
the uh who the hell wants to go to the
military right we're busy right but
still in a in a free country where you
they people have that option you see
enough people
are passionate about defending america
that they're willing to uh sign up for
the military right
and they get paid for it in a free
society i think you would see a lot of
people
uh voluntarily funding the military i
mean it's
it would be bizarre to think that you
know let's say donald trump see let me
say something nice about trump
old donald trump you know apprentice
donald trump doing all these charity
events donald trump
we're gonna have a concert lil john and
sugar ray that's mark mcgrath sugar ray
we're gonna have
i never tried doing a trump impression
before by the way so i i know
it's coming off a little bit cringy as
the kids would put it
but i mean he would have a concert you
know where uh mark mcgrath plays
every morning there's a hello oh there
he goes your monetization
girlfriend's point no that's fine bad
yeah that sounds nothing like him
yeah uh you know and people would buy
tickets and
a lot of the proceeds would go to
funding the military that's an example
of a fun way to raise money for the
military
but other than that it would just be
wealthy successful people that love
america that want to defend it for
selfish reasons
would uh fund the military so but half
as many of that
i think most people would not do it i
think maybe conservatives who are like
you know
i think you're wrong but even even if
ten percent there's a ten
even in today's world in a in today's
largely regulated
world america which is a fraction of the
level of prosperity it could be
you you would have even if today's top
10 percent who i keep hearing about
today's 10 percent have all the money
one percent have all the money
that one percent could fund the military
right so like but would they
they could and if the alternative is
having a weak country that gets invaded
by all types of crazy asians then
obviously they would do it
but i mean again remember we live in the
age of pragmatism where most people are
not thinking
that long term to them everything's
short term and how do i feel right now
so we need people that treat their life
the way they treat their business
they're looking at the
the next 10 years they're looking at the
next 50 years and just
you know that proverb a society grows
great when old men
plant trees whose shade they know they
will never sit beneath that's beautiful
and uh what does that mean let's talk
about this i like this why
why do old men plant a tree they will
never get to sit beneath so that the
children who come after them will have
shade to sit under
yes and also why do they care about
children in the f
after they're dead i don't know why
because while they're alive they
love life they love being alive they
love
many people that they know they love
seeing children learn to walk and sit
under trees
they love life they love their animals
they love their plants
you know they're passionate about life
and and
all these things and then to them the
idea of just planting a tree means that
at that moment their life had value like
they were they were pursuing their own
value they love
they love what that planting represents
and uh they get to lay in their death
bed
and maybe even be reminded of that
little tree and die with a smile on
their face so it's their personal values
it's not altruism it's not
oh i i'm just gonna sacrifice this time
and this seed and plant it even though
i'll get nothing out of it that's just
such an ugly
uh thing to strive for it's it's selfish
but in a rational way in a beautiful way
i'm not i'm not one who would favor a
command economy quite the opposite
but i also think not literally the
opposite end of the spectrum which would
be
an unplanned competitive market where
you don't know if you're gonna have the
budget you need to defend yourself from
an attack from an adversary like china
i think there's got to be some planning
and if there's some planning we have to
have some budgeting
so that means taxes again i believe in
having a military the government's
it should be the government doing it not
bill gates not steve jobs maybe some of
the technology those guys come up with
should be
uh licensed whatever by the government
i'm not there i'm not a legal
philosopher believe it or not
believe it or not i am a i'm a dropout
but i'm saying
but i'm saying the government should
have a military and that they should
be able to figure out what is the budget
and then is the society willing
to pay for that budget and then if the
answer is no which i don't think it
would be
if the answer is no then that country
has a problem on its hand and
that's true it doesn't deserve it
doesn't deserve it by the way you would
you would fund the military i would not
well not today's military with all their
bs but
in a rational society if you knew the
military's job was explicit and clear
and limited
and i was in charge of it you trust you
know i'm a good general right you know
i'm
i care you know you've seen me talk
about the rights of the individual and
the american philosophy of its founding
and all these things and you know that
the president agrees with that too
and and i'm his general and we're going
out to deal with chinese
forces that are violating the rights of
americans you would have some money to
volunteer
i think he's made a really good point if
people were not willing to fund the
military
then we do have a problem and the only
reason we're able to engage in a lot of
trash wars
that seem to fail in the middle east is
because people are forced to fund the
military and so
i wonder if that regardless of whether
you're forced to pay for it or you
wouldn't choose to pay for it shows a
larger problem breaking
a larger break in this country in
general
not only that people are forced to to
pay taxes but also
uh again people they don't hold dear the
rights of the individual they don't see
their own life
as their standard of value they don't
see their own life as something to
to die protecting how do you feel about
conscription against it
but the founding fathers were for it
they were wrong yeah how about that
yeah about that bro good point so uh how
do you feel about second amendment
i think i'm for it but it's not this is
gonna okay now if anyone doesn't hate me
yet
i'm gonna piss them off and say in my
opinion in not everyone agrees with me
in my opinion the right to bear arms is
not as fundamental as the right to
property and the right
to speech what i mean is your property
as a billionaire
you're right as a billionaire to own
your big
uh crappy silicon valley company
is more synchro synced to me than the
the right to own a gun
i know i i hate to pick which one is
more important but
i'm the opposite right without the right
to property the right without the right
to
to own what you how do you protect you
what you how do you protect what you've
produced
if you can't have the question first is
do you have an inalienable right to that
property
yes if you say yes and from my cold dead
hands take this property
then we can talk about okay well is in
is individual civilians owning guns
a a meaningful effective way to protect
property rights and maybe the answer is
yes
in which case i'm for it but it's
derivative the first comes property
rights see what i'm saying i agree i
agree because the gun is property as
well
if you have no right to property well
but it's but it is conceivable and
you're gonna hate me for this but it is
conceivable that weapons
some weapons are not a right to own
because they they
they cause more destruction and some
companies cause massive destruction like
the cuyahoga
river which was mass polluted and burst
into flames so i think you would agree
that we were
well if the rivers were privately owned
then
the owner of that river would be able to
file a lawsuit and uh retire
privately owned i could carry a weapon
on my own private property
depending again on how the legal
philosophers
determine what it is that the individual
needs in order to live
a rational life in a free society but
what what if people are speeding down my
road dangerously and they're
violating my my my rights taking gun and
try and stop them
i think you set the speed limit but this
is very advanced legal philosophy
so so i'm look you know you're saying
that
a gun isn't the same level of there may
be some guns you should not have for a
variety of reasons because they can
cause more damage
i think massive companies cause massive
damage listen
those are two very different types of um
questions should an individual be able
to own it like losing
disaster that you know kills hundreds of
thousands of people versus someone with
a gun who might kill dozens
listen the right to kill somebody is not
yours
like unless it's self-defense right but
polluting someone else's property is
always wrong no matter what there's no
such thing as polluting someone else's
river
i'm trying to find that distinction
between some guns can be very dangerous
so you can't have them versus some
companies can be
very dangerous but you can still have
them in what way are companies dangerous
so like uh if you have say a uh
semi-auto
50 bmg anti-materiel rifle you're not
intending to use that you shouldn't be
to harm another person who is innocent
using it to protect yourself your
property
from you know helicopters and tanks that
might violate your property or
for the most part we we agree in the
united states you can defend yourself
from lethal harm
reasonable fear if like you know if
somebody is threatening you
you have a way to defend yourself and
it's typically if you think they're
going to kill you
right so it is wrong to take a gun
and use it for the purpose of
intentionally inflicting death upon
someone who is not
threatening you in any way or or you
know coming at you right
right so that would be a violation to
use that weapon that was too dangerous
in a dangerous way
okay well the intended purpose of say a
chemical processing plant is to provide
petrochemicals to individuals like
cleaning solutions and fuels
it is not the intended purpose to blow
up and poison hundreds of thousands of
people
but they but it can as a 50 bmg semiauto
can be used to kill innocent people
so which one do we regulate or do we
regulate none of them
well regulation is is different than um
it making things illegal that are too
dangerous so i don't know exactly what
should be legal when it comes to like
what's too dangerous for
for people to have obviously a private
company cannot build their own atom bomb
and then
hold it over a neighboring city and say
well it's my property
no i mean you need to look at what is
the type of society where an individual
again can look at the world
choose his rational values and pursue
them without anyone else impeding on
them
and there i don't think there's any
there's i think you need guns
okay fine but my point is and i didn't
need to pick this battle
part in the pun because i could have
just said yeah you have the right to
bear arms and everyone in the chat room
would
would stop hating me and i'll be
laughing and we would yeah and i would
get to throw some red meat
to all of the second amendment people
but i just want to be philosophical
about this and say the right to bear
arms is derivative
first comes the right to property and
the reason you have a right to own
property is because in order to live
you need to produce and you have the
right to speak because
speech is a expression of thought so
i i i agree with the property part and
uh and look
i i i understand your opinions i'm not
saying they're wrong
i have opinions of opinions i just think
that it is derivative the right to own
property comes first
and i think bearing arms is more
fundamental to the individual
than the billionaire individual so well
let me or the corporation so i'll
clarify
if you're somebody who works you know
breaks your back every day you know
farming and raising chickens or whatever
there are bad people who will steal i
mean this is this is a this is a thing
that exists
there are also animals that don't
consider it theft
it's scavenging and opportunism the
right to bear arms can protect you from
those animals who would strip away what
you've produced but also criminal
individuals who would as well
so we can even remove the the bad
thieves from the equation
and say all right what about a fox and a
coyote come on your property
can you protect yourself and your
chickens from that coyote well you'll
need a gun or at least some kind of
weapon
and i don't think you're gonna be going
up against coyotes with the machete i
think you'd be hard-pressed to find
a free-market person who is opposed to
you know comp either bearing arms or
certainly companies protecting
themselves from wild animals i think the
the controversy comes up when it comes
to
big weapons and many many weapons so i
mean if the standard is
we need a society where the individual
is able to
um who pursue the life that he wants
without being interrupted by outside
people then
again speech and property are the
fundamentals and then
the right to protect your property and
person with a gun
it's reasonable see again i could have
let this one go easy but i wanted to
be a little uh you know a bit of a heart
just to clarify that it's i think it's
derivative and then i think just to kind
of cap off this conversation when it
comes to
corporation versus corporation or
individual just legal lawsuits civil
courts and stuff is
i think reasonable anybody would agree
with right like
if like a corporation was say polluting
a river and that
and that was affecting a farmer who's
like a small farmer he would file a
lawsuit
yeah the courts the river by the way
would not be publicly owned the
river owner would be able to sue much
quicker than
how does one person own an entire river
would it be a corporation that owns it
either that yeah usually i think look i
mean it's hard for me to tell you how it
would work but i mean
back when property was mostly um
corporations were a new thing it wasn't
the brooklyn bridge like the first
corporation
no corporations existed in the times of
the founders it was
it was an american innovation i believe
i just read about this in a journal
called the objective standard
but wasn't it like they were temporary i
don't think so i think there's a lot of
anti-corporate sentiment
in the world in the intellectual world
what's it's all what i was kidding i
said it's all propaganda
it is i think it is i mean there's both
anarchists
a lot of libertarians obviously leftists
and a lot of these
populist nationalists they all see
corporations as some bastardization of
the idea of property rights and all that
but really it is taking property rights
and
and kind of making them better uh
protected
in a in a marketplace so i'm
pro-corporation obviously
you're a corporate entity yourself i'm a
corporate entity we are surrounded by
the fruits
of corporate efforts honestly this is
going to piss off
the last person watching this that does
not hate me i
liked because i think i know what he
meant i liked when
mitt romney in 2012 said corporations
are people because i think i
i think i know what he meant to say is
that we're talking about corporations as
though they're
floating some floating aliens that have
nothing to do with the american
no corporations are people my friend the
the creators the workers the owners and
the shareholders and the customers are
all people
do you think that's what he meant like
corporations are comprised of people
that's
what i think he meant he did not mean to
say that literally these corporations
have a name and zip code and social
security i think they are legally aren't
they legally persons they're
they're legal persons for the sake of
like lawsuits and things like that
you know yeah that was that one but
right right used to be i think it's
it's a matter i think the whole thing
was a semantic argument to be fair
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time